c'était une trêve unilatérale annoncé
par Poutine et les Ukrainiens n'ont pas
suivi parce que dès le début et bien il
n'y croyait pas et hier à travers tout
le pays les alertes auraient aériens les
sirènes ont grondé on les a entendu ici
à Kiev également il y a eu des frappes
sur la ville de cramator ce que dans le
Dombasle qui ont détruit près de 14
domicile selon le maire et puis à
baroute et bien les combats ont continué
comme avant la trêve donc il n'y a
vraiment pas vraiment eu de changement
sur le front et puis avec les sirènes
etc vraiment rien n'a changé pour les
Ukrainiens finalement ça ressemblait à
une journée comme une autre alors il
faut dire aussi que la tension continue
ici côté
ukrainien pour ces jours de Noël
orthodoxe même si beaucoup d'Ukrainiens
ont cette année célébré le 25 décembre
pour se distancier de l'Église orthodoxe
russe il y en a encore beaucoup qui vont
se rendre à la messe vont célébrer Noël
et les autorités ukrainiennes sont
inquiète notamment sur les territoires
occupés par la Russie elle conseille aux
Ukrainiens de ne pas se rendre à la
messe d'éviter les lieux où il y a
beaucoup de monde car elle craignent les
attaques justement peut-être sur les
églises pendant la messe ou bien sur les
endroits où les gens pourraient être
réunis et même ici à Kiev à la Lavra où
va se tenir une messe de Noël et bien il
y a un énorme dispositif de sécurité
avec beaucoup de policiers les
Ukrainiens restent sous tension ne croit
pas donc à se cesser le feu qui est vu
comme un outil de communication
politique et donc tout le monde reste
sur le qui-vive